نعم نعم نعم حان وقت الاعتراف هلف النيت
يعترف واوكرانيا بتلك الزاويه تندب حظها
وروسيا تتجاهل وتشم هجمات عنيفه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه واشنطن هجوم كييف
المضاد ستعمه الفوضى وفصل الشتاء قد ياتي
بالنهايه وكندا تقدم دعما سخيا للدفاع
الاوكراني وبعد ان عاد كم من روسيا محملا
بالهدايا التحالف العسكري يبلغ ذروته بينج
وموسكو وبولندا تستعرض عضلاتها العسكريه
امام اعين الجيران والعين ترمق حلفاء
بوتين فهل يرد الكرملين هذه المره في
ليبيا الكارثه تتجاوز 21 الفا من الضحايا
والزياده ممكنه في اي لحظه وبعض من بصيص
الامل في المغرب بعد زلزال والاعلان عن
اول حلف دفاعي في افريقيا وبكين تواصل بث
الرعب في الجزيره التايوانيه خيانه
الحلفاء ضربه العدو تؤلم مره بينما ضربه
صديقي تؤلم مرتين واوكرانيا لم تعد تعلم
من اين ستاتيها الضربه القادمه فها هو
رئيس اللجنه العسكريه لحلف شمال الاطلسي
النيتو يعترف بان طلبات اوكرانيا من
الاسلحه والذخائر وكذلك حجم المنتجات
الدفاعيه المستخدمه في اوكرانيا تتجاوز
قدرات الحلف مضيفا ان دول النيتو التي
تقرر توريد الاسلحه والذخيره الى كييف
بحاجه الى التفكير في المخاطر المرتبطه
بمثل هذا القرار على امنيها وامن الحلفاء
اي انه يقول اعلن تامين نفسه قبل ان يؤمن
اوكرانيا فهل وصلت الرساله ايها الاوكران
باور لم ينتهي بعد ليعود ويؤكد ان التقدم
البطيء لقوتك في هجومها المضاده لا يسببه
النقص في حجم الذخيرهم الوضع الصعب في
ساحه المعركه فضلا عن حقول الالغام الامر
لم يقتصر على النيتو وهنا صحيفه
الامريكيه تقول ان فصل الشتاء القادم
سيتسبب في ارباك الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
نتيجه تساقط الثلوج والامطار وتضيف
الصحيفه الامريكيه ان الطرق ستكون موحله
وستعجز المركبات والاسلحه الثقيله عن
التحرك لتبدا اشارات انتهاء الهجوم من
الحليف الامريكي ليزيد الامين العام لحلف
الناتو
اوكرانيا بيله بقوله معظم الحروب تستمر
لفتره اطول من المتوقع عندما تبدا للمره
الاولى لذلك علينا ان نهيئ انفسنا لحرب
طويله الامد في اوكرانيا واضاف ان الجميع
يتمنى تحقيق سلام سريعا ولكن في الوقت
نفسه يجب الادراك انه اذا توقف الرئيس
زلنسكي والاوكرانيون عن القتال سوف تختفي
اوكرانيا من الوجود وفق تعبيره وذلك في مق
مع مجموعه بنك الاعلاميه الالمانيه لكن
برغم كل تلك المحبطات جاء بصيص امل من
كندا حيث اعلنت الحكومه الكنديه
وستساهم بحوالي 24 مليون دولار امريكي في
شراكه دوليه تقودها بريطانيا لتوفير قدرات
الدفاع الجوي للكييف مالا مالا اذا كانت
عشرات المليارات من الغرب لم تنفع بشيء
الى الان فما الذي بامكان هذه الملايين
القليله ان تفعل يا للعجب لننتقل الى
روسيا حيث كان الزعيم كوريا الشماليه
قبل ايام ثم غادر لكنه لم يغادر خالي
الوفاض حيث ذكرت وكاله الانباء المركزيه
الكوريه الشماليه انا كيم ناقش مسائل
عمليه لتعزيز التعاون العسكري مع وزير
الدفاع الروسي فيما وصفته بانها ذروه
جديده للعلاقات الثنائيه مما افادت وسائل
اعلام روسيه
حصل على هدايا عسكريه قبل مغادرته لروسيا
وهي عباره عن ستره واقيه اخف بكثير من
الدروع المعروفه المماثله كما تسلم خمسه
طائرات مسيره انتحاريه بالاضافه الى مسيره
استطلاع من طراز جيران
مصنعه في المنطقه العسكريه الشماليه
الروسيه هذا نابار اما ما خفي فهو اعظم
ليعلن وزير الدفاع في كوريا الشماليه
على استعداد لتعزيز الاخوه العسكريه مع
القوات المسلحه الروسيه والدفاع عن السلام
والاستقرار في المنطقه وعلى سطح الكوكب
وفق اذاعه صوت كوريا انه اعلان للتحالف ضد
الغرب رسميا اليس كذلك يا ساده وبالعوده
الى المعارك في اوكرانيا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسي
دمرت سته مسيرات اوكرانيه حاول التنفيذ
هجوم ارهابيا قباله الساحل الغربي لشبه
جزيره القرم هذا واعلنت الوزاره الروسيه
ايضا القضاء على نحو 625 جنديا اوكرانيا
واسقاط 28 مسيره وقنبلتي جدام موجهين
وصواريخ امريكيه على مختلف محاور العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه وذلك كما جاء في المصدر
وفقا ما تشاهدونه في الموقع الرسمي
للحكومه الروسيه في المقابل اشار الجيش
الاوكراني الى ان روسيا اطلقت سته طائرات
مسيره ايرانيه صنع من طراز شاهد عشره
صواريخ كروز وانا دفاعاته الجويه دمرت سته
طائرات مسيره وسته صواريخ قبل اصابه هدفها
لتعود الدفاع الروسي وتؤكد تدمير مصنع
للدبابات كانت تستخدمه قوتك لاعاده تاهيل
وصيانه الدبابات والمدرعات ونقاط مراقبه
وقياده للجيش الاوكراني واليكم المصدر
بعيدا عن الحرب الاوكرانيه الى جارتها
بولندا حيث استعرضت وارسو احدث اسلحتها
وانظمتها الدفاعيه بما في ذلك دبابات ابرز
الامريكيه صنع دبابات الجنوبيه جاء ذلك
خلال مناورات عسكريه ضخمه تحت اسم نار
الخريف زامنت مع تصاعد التوترات على
حدودها مع بيلاروسيا واستعداد البلاد
لانتخابات رئاسيه الشهر المقبل الاحداث
والتطورات الحكومه الليبيه الفيضانات دمرت
ما لا يقل عن 891 مبنى بمدينه درنه هذا
واعلن مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه ارتفاع عدد قتل السيول في مدينه
درنه وحدها الى
11,300 قتيل على الاقل واضاف ان عدد
المفقودين في درنك بلغ 10,000 ومئه شخص
كما قال مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه ان عدد النازح شمال شرق ليبيا
ارتفع الى نحو اربعين الفا والى المغرب
حيث لا تزال السلطات المختصه تقوم باحصاء
الخسائر البشريه والتراثيه والماديه عدد
الاسر المعنيه بشكل نهائي وفق التوجيهات
الملكيه في اطار تفعيل البرنامج
الاستعجالي لاعاده ايواء المتضررين
والتكفل بالفئه الاكثر تضررا من زلزال
الحوز وبحسب تقديراتنا كشف معهد المسح
الجيولوجي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
اضرار زلزال الحوز قد تكلف المغرب فاتوره
باهظه ثمن تقدر ما بين واحد الى تسعه
مليارات يورو
في وزاره الصحه المغربيه شفاء نحو
4800 شخص من الزلزال الذي ضرب المغرب
المسؤول المغربي اضاف بان عمليه العلاج
تسير بوتيره منسقه وتشمل علاجا نفسيا
وطبيا للمتضررين من الكارثه الذين يصل
عددهم لخمسه الاف ومئتي
[موسيقى]
الجمال والنيجر وبوركينا فاسو اتفاقا
امنيا تعهدت فيه بمساعده بعضها البعض في
حاله وقوع اي تمرد او عدوان خارجي في اول
حلف دفاعي افريقي ياتي ذلك بعد توتر
علاقات هذه الدول مع الجيرانها وشركاء
الدوليين بسبب الانقلابات العسكريه
الاخيره اعلنت سلطات تايوان رصدا 28 طائره
حربيه صينيه قرب سواحل الجزيره عبر معظمها
خط الوسط الذي يفصل بين تايوان والبر
الصيني الرئيسي
[موسيقى]